das stimmt nicht was im internet steht
schallock luca wir befinden uns hier
heute nämlich auch bei uns altbekannten
website house.net how auto ein lockout
tagout rovers von robotern besser denn
überhaupt in seiner fresse kleben
auf dieser website können wir bilder
hochladen die wir auf unserem laptop ich
hab das an der brille hier dieser
website hier können wir entweder
ausbildern auswählen die hier schon
vorhanden sind und können beispielsweise
klicken judo und wir sehen ob er ist auf
dem bild 25 jahre alt also so wie hier
auf dem bild aus was wir allerdings
machen werden nicht dass irgend ein foto
von den hinnehmen werden sondern wir
klicken auf youtube ein photon dann
fügen wir dort bilder von youtube ein
die erste person von der wir heute das
alte herausfinden wollen ist ein youtube
oder muss ich sagen ich schaue sehr
wenig youtuber reflektiere ich
allerdings wichtig für den konsens bei
dem denke ich mir wirklich bei jedem
hochgeladenen einsame 1
da ist ein
einsame spitze nicht einsam sahne ich
will euch gar nicht mehr lange gefoltert
ist natürlich luca
der beste youtuber von hinten die wehr
hat erste bilder einfach mal dass sie
mit kollegen aus und ich glaube das hat
mir sogar schon mal analysiert
ich dachte die website hat sich
verbessern hat sie anscheinend nicht ich
bin hier wirklich auf 36 gestellt worden
also ich finde da kann man wirklich mal
dann körperlich marodieren house.net
die beschäftigte website zum alter
schätzen die irgendwie auf die sache
aber freunde wir probieren einfach mal
andere foto von mir aus also wir kriegen
wieder drauf deen e mails beispielsweise
mandate dazu noch gar nicht so alt 21
also ich bin ein 20 deswegen bin ich
gerade erstaunt die man natürlich kann
diese webseite richtige alter raus wenn
ich meine ich bin hier sherlock luca am
start und die website und ihren
kombinationen immer das richtige alter
von youtube man raus aber das ist echt
irre dass ich hier wirklich auf 21
geschätzt wurde ich wollte halt echt nur
bis heute bilder von mir nehmen und ab
bewegen dafür genommen wo ich viel und
ich dachte er kennt mich darauf nicht
mehr aber 21 ist sehr sehr gut hier
klicken trotzdem mal wieder frei
foto youtube auto weil ich habe noch
zwei weitere top vorbereitet einmal
dafür ruhig
ok
ich wurde noch nie jünger geschätzt als
ich aussehe
ich habe übrigens kate auch nur auf weil
ihr seht schon das ist das ist
2000 jahre später
ja manchmal doch einmal so weiter 24 bin
ich also auf diesem bild hat mich
gewundert ich sag mir der weg sogar im
bikini jünger aber ich würde sagen
einfach mal wie auf einer foto hilfe wie
dem letzten bild von mir auf dem luca
shop auf die 40 zu gast bin ich beim
ersten bild 37 jahre alt jetzt bin ich
hier bei 73 jahre alter jäger also hat
mich drei mal älter geschätzt als ich
bin froh dass ich dachte wie ich
dazwischen und das ist eine das ist eine
liebe die es wirklich da zusätzlich
immer wenig zu alt geschätzt werden will
und bedenken
in dem moment hier richtig im nächsten
youtube habe ich jetzt jemand gefehlt
der vom content her relativ ähnliche
videos macht und der auch vom aussehen
wie ihre brüder geringeres alten
anfangen
ja
gänzlich tanzverbot und kontraste die
verschollenen brüder genau als erstes
foto nehmen wir einfach mal das video 34
auch gar nicht sagen ich wurde auf 730
gestellt ich weiß nicht wie alt an
verboten echten ganz lustig dass
irgendetwas wissen aber wirklich rider
der porto youtube 29
ja
als er wirklich ist ein paar sekunden
später hans verbote 20 jahre alt what
the [ __ ] okay ich dachte jetzt wirklich
das irgendwie vielleicht vielleicht 24
50 oder so das wundert mich aber nicht
dass er freundlich ist weil ich bin ja
sherlock holmes und 23 meine damen und
herren tanzverbot wurde bisher noch
einmal so alt bringen wie er wirklich
ist ich hätte jetzt aber wirklich
gedacht muss ich zugeben dass er auch so
23 jahre wirklich als ist weil ich mein
hier sieht er ja relativ so aus relativ
genau so aus wie ein video doch
ausschließt aber hey
hättet ihr gedacht das kann vor bald
zwanzig ist als letztes foto von
tanzverbot nehmen wir jetzt dass hier
david einem jahr
die 34 und ja ich weiß dass das rehwild
ihr müsst mir nicht tausende kommentare
schreiben regie wurde mir nur angezeigt
als die tanzverbot gegoogelt habe ich
will mich da als gar nicht weit aus dem
fenster lehnen aber ich finde eine
gewisse ähnlichkeit auf jeden fall da
also wenn man sich mal nur den den mund
und den ball anguckt dann könnte auf
jeden fall tanzverbot sein wenn man dann
wiederum augen nase und da muss man
schon sagen nicht mehr tanzen sondern
wie eine grobe missgeburt warschau dort
an der stelle an die übrigen kommt die
tage auch noch ein video mit revue die
frage ob ihr euch jetzt freut oder heute
wirklich sagen ich traue ich auch wert
du auf mir auch relativ wenig ich nehme
nur youtuber die mir ähnlich denen heute
hatte ich letztens wirklich von vizrt in
der musikbranche hat sage ich mal ist ja
auch sehr sehr oft genug sagen wie gut
das gelungen
sie hat zahlreiche negativ reise zu
ihren hits bekommen ist alle berge meine
bianca ich habe bilder von bianca hier
wir nehmen als erstes mal 14 von 24 da
hatte sie irgendeinen sich mit auf dem
kopf wie wir jetzt auch schon 24
das hätte ich nie gedacht ich dachte
auch diverse alt wie ich zu 21 oder
irgendwie so aber okay die wird auf dem
bild auch auf 24 geschäft von daher ist
das natürlich derzeit alle komplett
vernünftigkeit lebte vorzunehmen jetzt
auch ein wenig ein älteres dort ist die
27 lustig weil auf dem foto war sie
locker gerade mal 19 oder so
aber freunde ihr habt ihr mit house.net
und luca solarlog ist wird kann ich
meinen eigenen namen nicht mehr
aussprechen
als nächstes foto nehme mir ein foto von
ihr und julian beide auf 27 ist auf
jeden fall auch sympathisch dazu
webseiten beide direkt drei jahre älter
einschätzt ist julia überhaupt 24
also glaube ich mal weil wenn sie
zusammen sind und sich also das ist
wieder eine richtige luca logik wenn man
mit einer person zusammen das muss man
das gleiche alter haben wir werden auf
jeden fall beide auf 720 geschätzte
klicken jetzt zum letzten mal auf
youtube user weil ich hier noch ein foto
von baby habe laut ist die 31 da muss
ich auch sagen sieht sich nicht ganz so
aus die wirklich aussieht ist ja auch
wieder der wahnsinn meine damen und
herren wir jetzt gerade wirklich
aufgefallen
mittlerweile ein besucher sogar product
placement von billy am start sind mensch
freude
womit verdient dieses mädel kein geld
wahrscheinlich verdiente sogar in meinem
video hier etwas doch wahrscheinlich ist
es wirklich wird kombi nun wirklich zu
einem youtuber den man gar nichts über
den spann ist wenn eine gruppe von
personen
ich denke jetzt vielleicht
herausragendste produzierenden hate
crime jungen oder eröffnet ich weiß wie
die unasur oder die außenseiter oder
radio oder sei die lobby oder
dennoch seien die senioren zocken und da
freue ich mich besonders darauf was da
für ein alter geschätzt wird gefangen
direkt an hier mit dem ersten foto 85
ich habe keine ahnung wie aldi sind
war
ich will mir jetzt auch nicht unbeliebt
machen aber es ist schon bemerkenswert
ist die website wirklich erkennt okay da
da befindet sich gerade eine ältere
person in diesem bild also 85 jahre
weiblich wird hier natürlich richtig
vorhergesagt deswegen klingt mir einfach
mal auf youtube ein foto und nehmen die
zweite senioren haben wir 84
sie gibt es übrigens gerade halb falls
ich finde das unglaublich krass wie weit
die technik einfach mittlerweile ist mal
ganz kurz hier
keycorp ne das ist ja unfassbar dazu
website einfach erstens ein gesicht
erkennt und an den gesichtszügen erkennt
die alt eine person ist hat nicht
unfassbar leute wenn ihr das umfasst
befindet dann lasst man leichter
grundlast auch man leicht dass jedermann
soll horizont.net habe ich in den
letzten jahren dreimal hochgeladen oder
so der natürlich noch mehr fotos von den
senioren und nehmen jetzt mal diese
tiere oder 90
bucher
da ist zu alt als wir
nehmen wir die wellen die wird sogar nur
62 geschäft das ist auf jeden fall
jünger als sie wirklich jetzt mag ich
jetzt mal so zu behaupten ich bin auch
schon kontakt mit dem eigentlichen
inhaber des kanals senioren sorgen das
ist nämlich ein grund glaube ich von
einem der senioren seniorinnen
die passwort mit dem hat jetzt auch
geschrieben weil wahrscheinlich jetzt
auch in diesem video wieder sehr viele
kommentare kommen werden von gm-europa
mach doch mal ein video mit den senioren
nicht ganz so einfach müsst ihr
verstehen die wohnung berlin ich wohne
in köln ich bin relativ häufig in berlin
dabei da habe ich mir dann termine und
bin halt relativ zeitlich eingespannt
allerdings vermehrt eine lösung für das
problem gefunden und zwei deren zwei
monaten die gamescom und dort werde ich
mit denen einen leistung machen noch ein
youtube kanal beziehungsweise zumindest
ein video aufnehmen und dann werde ich
zum ersten mal die senioren zog ich auf
meinem kanal zeigen aber hey winwood auf
jeden fall auf 62 deswegen würde ich
sagen an der stelle
sherlock luca setzt die brille wieder ab
und der normal dunkel und kalt wieder an
der stelle würde jetzt aber auch das
video endet meine damen und herren ich
hoffe es hat euch gefallen wie gesagt
wenn es euch getan
was
auf allen deutschen ebenen war das
komplett falsch gerade lassen waren
leichter freunde wenn euch das video
gefallen hat hier findet ihr zwei die
eingeblendet wenn ihr darauf könnte man
kanal abonnieren dort findet ihr auch
meinen shop eingeblendet in dem sich
jetzt immer noch lieferzeiten von bis zu
drei wochen
weil ihr beim launch der neuen produkte
vor vier wochen einfach viel zu krank
war und die hunderten weiteren video i